[Music]
in the last video we saw what stress and
strain meant in this video let's try
understanding their types both stress
and strain have two basic types normal
and shear so there's normal stress and
shear stress and normal strain and shear
strain will be discussing the former
type in this video that's the normal
type let's begin with normal stress when
you see the word normal in math or
physics what is it that you think of the
word normal in mathematics means
perpendicular so normal stress is simply
the force acting perpendicular to a
cross sectional area it is important to
note that the same applies to the
restoring force and the applied force
restoring force is simply a force that
tends to restore a deformed body to its
original form
that also is perpendicular now let's
come back to normal stress it's a force
acting perpendicular to a
cross-sectional area for example let's
take an object say a beam and try
stretching it the normal force that acts
on it is perpendicular to the cross
sectional area and a free try
compressing it the force will be
perpendicular but in this direction so
it either acts in this direction or in
the opposite direction that's the basic
concept of normal stress did you know
that normal stress can further be
divided into two sub categories they are
called tensile stress and compressive
stress look at the napes and try to
decode their meanings you will easily be
able to tell what compressive stress
means when the normal force is
compressing the object the stress
experienced by the object is called
normal compressive stress or simply
compressive stress what good tensile
stress mean then tensile stress on the
other hand is a type of normal stress
where the force is stretching the object
note that in this
case the length of the beam will
increase okay we stressed enough about
the types of stress for now so let's
talk a bit about strain we know that
strain is nothing but the ratio of
change in length represented by Delta L
over the original length L since we've
already seen what tensile and
compressive stress means could you guess
what tensile and compressive strain
would be yes normal strain is also
classified into these two types this
formula remains the same in both the
cases of tensile and compressive strain
except that in the case of tensile
strain Delta L is the amount by which
the length increased and in the case of
compressive strain Delta L is the amount
by which the length decreased in the
next video we will discuss what shear
stress and shear strain mean don't
forget to tune in
[Music]
you